just the simple task of washing dishes
can be dangerous here doing laundry
catastrophic
annapurna lives in the eastern indian
state of odisha she shows us her feet
where she was once attacked by a
saltwater crocodile
her friend parvati remembers her brother
who was pulled under
villages started shouting when the
crocodile took my brother but it is such
a powerful animal what could we have
done to fight strength everyone felt
that like something would happen since
their numbers are rising it took my
brother away i just don't understand why
a nearby national park is known for
having one of the highest number of
saltwater crocodiles in the world
after the government introduced
conservation efforts in the nineteen
seventies the number of crocodiles
increased from fewer than a hundred to
nearly two thousand
during india's monsoon season this river
swells making it easier for the
crocodiles to encroach on the villages
nearby
but now when the water levels go down
the crocs don't leave instead they stay
and lay their eggs posing a serious
threat to people people have started
co-existing with saltwater crocodile but
we need to have some kind of mitigation
measures
even with the predators looming in the
water daily chores must go on something
mainly done by women and children but
everyone faces the threat at some point
people come here to wash up and cattle
weighed in daily
we are completely dependent on this
river for drinking water and other needs
for the past one and a half years the
terror of crocodiles has seeped in among
the villagers that we are afraid to come
near the river
but we have to
because we are dependent on it
from the nearly 200 thousand people who
depend on this delta life now involves a
constant fear of what's lurking
underneath the muddy waters
leah harding al jazeera